so will restarting this remain and
mexico policy stop the flow of illegal
immigrants coming across the southern
border i want to bring in texas
department of public safety lieutenant
chris oliveiras uh thank you lieutenant
for joining us do you believe that to be
the case will will this help the problem
you've been facing sir
well good afternoon senator thanks for
thanks for having me on great to be with
you so again this remaining mexico
policy remains to be seen as far as how
effective it's going to be for this
current border crisis this is something
that should have been done at the
beginning of the year but we're almost a
year into this border crisis and there
has been no action
taken upon the federal government to try
to curb or deter or stop this border
crisis so again it remains to be seen
how effective it's going to be but i can
tell you right now what the state of
texas is doing what we've been doing
since day one
under the leadership and guidance of
governor greg abbott our state
legislatures our state leadership we are
cracking down on these illegal we are
cracking down on criminal activity the
human smugglers drug smugglers that are
coming into the state of texas because
it not only affects the state of texas
it affects the entire country but
because of them we've been able to
provide we've been able to have more
resources more equipment more technology
to help us secure the border that's what
we've been doing ever since this border
crisis took place i'm trying to get a
sense from you whether or not you think
this is going to help the situation i
know you're saying it's a little too
little too late
but there are some suggesting um and
this is a local attorney suggesting that
people are going to die because of this
remaining mexico policy saying that
instead of being let into the u.s
they're going to be put into these camps
essentially refugee camps in mexico this
has been the case against that remain in
mexico policy so now that it's being
re-implemented will at least help from
your view
well senator i could take this right now
that the criminal organizations the
smuggling organizations have profited
off this border crisis since the very
beginning they're making millions
hundreds of million dollars a month just
by smuggling illegal immigrants across
the border and i can tell you right now
they're going to continue to smuggle
these illegal immigrants across the
border they're going to change their
tactics and one thing that we need to
focus on too aside from the families and
unaccompanied children we have the
single adults that are coming across we
have seen a significant increase in
single adults that are coming across our
borders not only the rio grande valley
but in the del rio sector as well and
these are the individuals that are
coming across avoiding detection so
regardless of title 42 or the remaining
mexico policy these individuals are
still coming across our borders and
they're still trying to make it further
inland and these are individuals that
have ties to transnational criminal
organizations some are criminal gang
members so that's what we need to focus
on right now and that's what our men and
women of texas dps are focusing on is
that criminal element it is a massive
problem that is growing that you face
every day white house press secretary
jensachi was asked today about
reinstating this remain in mexico policy
and said this listen
it is not our preference to be
re-implementing and reinstituting the
migrant protection program uh we
protocol uh we are doing that uh because
of uh court order and legal uh
requirement to do so but we still feel
that the program is inefficient and
humane and we are not uh we weren't we
did not eagerly reimplement it i should
say lieutenant your response to that
so that just goes to show you right
there uh sandra that there has no uh
intent to fix this border crisis when it
could have been taking place from the
very beginning but again as she just
mentioned right there they're not in
favor of this remaining mexico policy
but they are forced they are forced
under a court order to reinstate the
policy and i can tell you right now it's
going to be a slow process and it
remains to be seen how effective it's
going to be but i can assure you right
now and i can assure the american people
that the state of texas is going to
continue cracking down on this criminal
element and trying to tear and disrupt
these criminal organizations from
propping off this border crisis right
now we really appreciate your time thank
you sir huge task thank you thank you
for your time hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else